so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
happy week one nfl football is back
thank god it is finally here happy
sunday everyone you just tapped into vr
betting squad ride presented by
draftkings live in the bleacher report
app that's right my name is connor
rogers alongside the man of the people
the guy you want to get on his good side
because you want to win these giveaways
that is greg ivory man i can't wait for
today greg what's the over under a
number of hoodies you're giving away
today
over under connor whatever it is just
hammer the over matter of fact
let me introduce the people that don't
know
this right here is the handy dandy ipad
and this is how you get your jerseys
this is how you get your hoodies this is
how i see you and how you see me on the
bleacher report app you see what i did
there connor that's true right there
actually
i'm feeling good man it's nfl you know
it's first week week one
about to give out some hoodies right now
why not about to give out some hoodies
right now i got master jedi
master jedi says use the force and trust
master jedi justin jefferson and travis
kelsey scores touchdowns today shout out
to you master jedi you
are walking away with the first
hoodie of the squad ride show in week
one shout out to you man
that's right and that's man we've seen a
lot of people taking kelsey and he's
already given away our jam here a little
bit greg this is the show where we're
looking for anytime touchdown scores
who's getting in the end zone we need to
know and that's chosen by you the squad
that's the point of this thing so on
friday we asked you on social we ask you
in the vr app the betting stream to drop
your locks to score a touchdown these
are the most popular picks you sent us
so far no surprise the king at the top
the man that finds the end zone it feels
like every week in derrick henry some
other good running backs in dalvin cook
and christian mccaffrey then the top
wide receivers devonte adams and tyreek
hill some underdog picks here rahim most
are healthy for that niners ground
attack i know that makes you happy greg
jonathan taylor newcomer on the block in
for a huge year in stephon diggs leading
the bill's mafia charge so before we get
started let's remind you how things go
around here let's look at some of our
favorite lock legends of last year
oh hey there bleach report betting
you're probably wondering what i'm doing
but it doesn't matter what i'm doing it
matters what delvin cook is going to do
on sunday to the cold defense
[Applause]
it's
[Music]
superman time for new england
[Music]
zeke's my pitch i really think it'll
make it happen
[Music]
who that baby
[Music]
[Music]
greg we know you've got the hoodies but
as always we're taking up things up a
notch this season what do you got for
the people
that's right connor
i'm not only giving away hoodies i'm
also giving away two not one but two nfl
jersey gift cards
one goes to the winning lock legend the
winner of the lock legend contest that
we're about to do and one goes to a
commenter at the end of the show so do
not go anywhere do not log out stay
right here because i'm giving away this
jersey and it might just be you get in
the comments do what you do if you need
a jersey if you need a hoodie
i need gifts i need emojis
and y'all know
and fill his comments up you all know
what i want i need winners only please
fill the comments up with winners only
please man i might give you all some
hoodies uh connor
let's keep this thing going man let's
keep this thing going absolutely we have
four legendary picks to show you and the
last one standing on top of the squad
ride gets actually gets an odd boost
from draftking so you want to stick
around and see where you can make that
money which touchdown score is getting
boosted this week that's what me and
greg are here to decide it's time for
round one our first pitch comes from
matt denhardig matt tell us who's
scoring a touchdown today let's see this
first pitch all right we got we got
travis kelsey right here for tk
and then we got george kittle right here
for gk so we're gonna see whoever hits
it closes whoever hits it close is gonna
score a touchdown this weekend
oh that's right
what we got
one ball right here what do we got
we got the tk
flags over there
we're going over here who do we got
we got
gk george kettle as way closer george
killed touchdown this weekend it's a
freaking lock let's go
shout out to matt and the boys there
shot via moto razor loving the first
pick here all right let's take a look at
our second one from su chi
alright let's see how this goes
how you doing just could you pay for the
car behind me too
and i just have one question for you you
watch football
oh yeah once in a while
pick one player devonta smith or
jonathan taylor
patriots no pick one of those players
devonta smith or jonathan taylor
taylor
perfect that's what i'll go with have a
good one
man i love asking strangers for help in
the betting world all right we've seen
the golf legends we've seen the toll
booth legend himself
greg what do you need from the people
right now and who are you rolling with
what i need the people to do is get in
the comments and tell me who we
should have move on to the next round is
it the golf legend or is it the toll
booth legend but let me talk about these
videos connor starting off with the golf
legend you know about the golf course i
know i've seen you there probably before
on instagram or twitter or whatever uh
but what do they say connor what do they
say about the golf like when about your
swing it's all in the hips and my guy at
the motion he had the motion i love the
play george kittle plus 125 you know the
niners are close to my heart so this
this video means something to me this
means something moving on to the toll
booth legend uh i like my guy panic four
i like my guy paying it forward he paid
for the guy the person behind him that
is ultimate sunset vibes right there
that is sunset that that's
vibes all around this guy deserves an
award uh the pick is good too john
taylor good pick connor it is a good
pick
and i'm not gonna tell you who i like
i'm not i'm not gonna tell you who i
like connor who do you like because i'm
i'm torn i'm honestly torn i am too you
gotta love those kid a lot plus 125 is
not bad i like the athleticism shown in
the golf legends video the guys are out
on the course having a good time but man
greg i'm rolling with jonathan taylor
not only do i like the pick i like the
style like you said he paid for the
people behind him you ask a complete
stranger you don't even know if he
watches football he's like ah a little
bit maybe that's what you say when you
don't know how to answer but the man was
decisive and went with jonathan taylor
what side of the people on right now
greg
connor let me grab this handy dandy ipad
and i got kp giants right here with the
gif know you guys can see it right there
that is jonathan taylor how does
jonathan taylor shout out to you kp
giants winners only please look at the
value taylor please shout out to you kb
giants you were walking away with a
hoodie uh
king fast also has the gift of jonathan
taylor hitting the whoa
hitting the wall there it is right there
uh shout out to you king fast you are
walking away with a
hoodie you're walking away with a hoodie
let's make a decision i i think it's
time to make a decision i'm seeing a lot
of george kettle shout out to everybody
that's saying george kittle but
i see more jonathan taylor's in the
comments
so therefore connor
it appears
sushi
is moving on
to the next round this hurts my heart
i know how i feel about george kittle
yeah you do but suchi well done but we
still have two more rounds you're not in
the clear yet we're not riding with
jonathan taylor just yet on to round two
our next pitch comes from riley serbo
who you got here riley let's see it
oh man
nothing like some ice cream oh thank you
so much
some ice cream to help me
make some locks today
you know what i'm saying oh
dang it oh what the
no way
derek
henry
king derek henry it is
ride it
the sprinkle legend going with derek
henry that's a smart man get your ice
cream and go with the safest pick of the
week the guy that scores has led the
league in rushing touchdowns now for the
last two years greg we're down here to
tollbooth legend the sprinkle legend who
do you like who do our people like
everybody that's watching
look at your phone look at your tablet
whatever you're on your device get your
fingers ready
and start typing who you think should
move on to the next round should it be
sprinkle legend or should it be toll
booth legend you guys let me know let me
hop in here
connor if you do not know last year
riley sorbo
legend he is a legend he he
like i'm gonna get to it i'm gonna tell
you everything that he did for us last
year but
he's a legend he's the mcdonald legend
he's the farm legend i can keep going i
can keep going but he's a legend and we
need to say his name riley sorbo he's a
legend
this video right here derek henry minus
225 sprinkles everything that he did
with the vid it looked like a
masterpiece it looked like i don't know
looking like a tick tock that i would
like or something it it i like it i like
the video i like to pick i'm done
talking connor what do you what do you
think i'm a huge fan of this right i
want to see -225 let's boost those odds
today now i'm selfishly rooting for this
one here greg i like the concept i love
the execution there the sprinkle legend
i think the sprinkle legend has to be
moving on but greg you still gotta give
away hoodies you still gotta let the
people pick what are they saying right
now
connor let me get into the comments
because i think that they are right
there with you i see a lot of sprinkles
shout out to daniel levy uh with the
gift right here of a guy just drinking a
lot of sprinkles shout out to you bro i
got
ny22gc got derek henry clapping in his
alabama uniform shout out to you
ny22 gc you're walking away with a
hoodie i got squad ride squad ride
i see what you did there they they they
got the squad ride as their uh as their
bleacher report handle name shout out to
you for the creativity you were walking
away with hoodie they also got derek
henry as a gift uh connor i think it's a
clear cut i don't even see
any johnson taylor's i just see derrick
henry so uh
guess what riley
once again
you are moving on to the next round
riley moving on well done and we're not
done yet we got one more round here that
riley has to get through another
contender we want to see who this who's
getting this jersey we want to see who's
more importantly going to be the squad
ride leader of this week of week one of
the nfl season all right next up w
trammell hopefully bringing the heat
let's see it w trammell
vr nation week one anytime touchdown
score see what we do
[Applause]
[Music]
the bucket legend the bucket toss
challenge going with bill's mafia's own
stefan
diggs love that greg did you see those
buckets the custom there they're out
there having a good time what do you
think of this one
hey the custom-made buckets are
legendary the throw was legendary the
pool it looked like a lazy river or
something it was legendary this whole
video is legendary and on top of all the
aesthetics of the video the details of
the video
the pick let's talk about the pit connor
stefan diggs you know how i feel about
this buffalo bills team this year
i mean come on plus 100
you know what we do here we're going to
odds boosted i think i might be leaning
towards this bucket legend uh connor
what are you thinking man it's my
favorite concept yet but not my favorite
pick right i i think the bills are going
to beat the steelers today i think
stefan diggs is one of those guys that's
good for 10 targets every single week
and there's a good chance he scores but
i know derek henry is going to score he
probably scores twice and i'm just
trying to get these odds boosted for the
sprinkle legend here i'm being selfish i
want this one to happen who is our first
squad leader of this season greg
connor i am in the comments hey you were
hilarious bro you said you know derek
henry is going to score i feel you man i
like that guaranteed money as well but
let me get into these comments and uh it
appears that the people in the comments
know derek henry is going to score as
well because i'm seeing a lot of derrick
henry in the com hold on hold on these
comments are moving i'm also seeing
stefan diggs they are riding with me i
got trashed trash says stefan dixie
threw a gif in there shout out to you
trash i got este bon cardona esteban
cardona he has stefan diggs winking he
has steph on this winky i'm going to
keep going though i'm going to keep
going into these comments i see
sprinkles spinkle sprinkles m-r-i-z-3
mri z3 has sprinkles all over the board
last one last one here connor i'm just
going to make a decision because it's
like it's crunch time or flowing
and it's crunch time and i just want
them to keep on flowing you know so i
can get gonna get a good good look at
what we should decide and it appears we
are going to go with derrick kennedy
smart you're going to go with derek
perry because uh abel matt abel matt
says king henry don't miss king henry
don't miss abel matt you are walking
away with the hoodie and that means my
guy the legend the hall the squad ride
hall of famer let's just let's just make
him that right now let's just call him
the squad ride hall of famer riley sorbo
is the winner of the first week's
squad ride locks legend uh video contest
shout out to you riley you may know him
as the chameleon legend you may know him
as the old macdonald legend he's uh
traded in animals for us uh for ice
cream and now he is our sprinkle legend
shout out to you riley you are taking
home a jersey now please please please
pull up that graphic from me please pull
up the graphic there it is that's it you
guys see derek henry you guys see derek
henry right there um
connor have you ever seen magic before
like disappear on your screen like no
i'm ready for this man during the show
during the show let me show you guys
magic are you guys ready here we go
saw that boom did you see that did you
did you see that
yeah
that's what we do here we change odds
just like that like it's like it's magic
uh
thanks to our friends at draftkings
we're gonna get that boost we're gonna
get that boosted for you guys from minus
225 to minus 150. uh check out brbetting
socials for a link to the odds boost
make sure you guys go check us out on
social so you guys can get the links to
the uh boost send us your screenshots of
your bets let's get rich connor let's
get rich it's football let's get rich
this sunday send us your videos and tag
your celebrations
but remember please remember and fill
the comments up once again
winners only
please connor we need winners only
please greg i know the hall of fame does
the gold jacket i think for us riley's
going to be getting fitted in a green
jacket how about that well done riley
week one legend and we're not done we're
not done the legends might be done the
squad ride leader might be done we got
more locks to talk we got hoodies to
give away and we still have a jersey to
give away so don't go anywhere and now
it's the community comment contest here
we want to see some best bets if you
hang out in the community stream in the
bleacher report app you know all about
this we asked you this week week one
what are your best bets you've got all
summer to think about this you don't
have six days you've literally had the
entire summer to get crazy with this we
picked two of our favorite comments and
we want to know what you think of each
of these
yes yes yes
i need you to get in the comments and
tell me which of these is the better
take
you guys got to let me know which one
we're going to show you which one of
these is the better it takes actually
let's take a look at it right now we got
uh my ssp right here says calvin ridley
lead the league balls evening
oh this is a bold one this is a bold one
connor let's move on to the next one we
have a
two-tone
not post malone
not carl malone but two-toned malone
saying titans are coming out of the afc
connor
what do you think man man i think we
jump to our next segment which is
boldest bets this is supposed to be best
bets each of these
are pretty bold and i respect that i
like it they're looking to make money
let's start with the last one titans
coming out of the afc titans in the
super bowl just sounds crazy they got a
really really good team they obviously
made some great moves this offseason
excited to see julio jones there we know
mike rabel can coach up the defense do
we think they're getting by the chiefs
or the browns or maybe even the patriots
or baltimore i don't know it's a tough
one for me i actually like the calvin
ridley there
that bet greg when you look at calvin
really he's going to be a target monster
and an offense that just lost julio
jones who's been the man for a decade
calvin ridley is one of the most
underrated receivers in the entire nfl
kyle pitts is gonna have his moments
there which makes me a little skeptical
but there's no reason calvin ridley
can't get 10 targets a game and at least
have a shot to be the receiving leader
so i liked it
hey connor honestly the people in the
comments are agreeing with you too they
like the calvin i've seen calvin really
uh
in the comments
uh hey i'm i'm just gonna start giving
out just giving out jerseys i mean not
jerseys but hoodies i'm sorry uh here we
go i i got uh guns burger
g-h-u-n-s guns burger says calvin ridley
lock shout out to you gal uh guns
gunsberger you're walking away with a
hoodie uh jackboy37 says calvin really
is a lock to lead the league and
receiving heard it here first
wow you people are really really really
bold with this calvin really uh play
i'll just announce it i'll just announce
it
ssp 17 you won man ssp 17 you won uh the
comment contest you are getting the
hoodie as well ssp 17 uh for your calvin
really take
shout out to you man you're a legend all
right to be our betting squad right show
best bets in the book now it's time for
boldest bets this is where i really want
the comments involved here greg boldus
bets who's gonna look smart who's gonna
look maybe not dumb because these are
long shots these are complete dart
throws here uh these are not locks this
is time to have fun let's get crazy
let's put a couple bucks down and win a
couple hundred bucks something along the
lines of that craig what do you need
from the people right now from boldest
bets
get in the comment and tell me whether
you're riding with me
what you should be or if you're riding
with my guy connor rogers over there uh
in his locks or his his play or his boat
is bet whatever he plays yeah this is
gonna be a marathon all right we gotta
get ready for this one right now so
i don't i think the people maybe should
go with you honestly but let's get right
into it this is my boldest bet of the
week it's a five pick parlay these odds
are over plus 1600 over plus 1600 let's
start with jets panthers ty johnson who
is going to be the jets lead back
over 24 and a half rushing yards oh my
god that should be four carries brandon
nyuk your boy greg over three and a half
receptions he's in for a monster year
for the 49ers kyle pitts the number two
option in atlanta over three and a half
receptions against the eagles rams first
half total over 13 and a half just need
two touchdowns from you in the first
half rams that's all we're asking for
sean mcvay you've had all summer matt
stafford with how good you are and how
this is going to be the time with the
rams let's see it the last one kareem
hunt over 16 and a half receiving yards
man that's one screen pass okay for
kareem hunt the tackle breaking machine
plus 16 10 here
i think it's a little crate how crazy am
i right now greg
hold on hold on hold on hold on pull
that back up let me see how crazy you
are i have to talk about this a little
bit love the iu play just have to say
that he's on my fantasy team so i
absolutely love that play neat over
three and a half receptions to hit uh
kyle pitts
maybe kind of skeptical but i wanted to
talk about this rams play
connor this rams play like i've been
seeing the rams to win the super bowl
rams to win the nfc rams to win the nfc
what like
is the hype really
real like do you think that this offense
is going to be one of the high powered
offenses of the league or something like
what's going on uh i think andy dalton
is going to throw at least an
interception or two in the first half
and i think the rams have at least one
offensive touchdown and maybe a
defensive touchdown in them as well this
is more about the bears i'm sorry bears
fans when justin fields gets in there i
can't wait to watch your team and i
think you're going to turn it around but
with andy dalton week one against the
rams don't think it's gonna be that so
listen it's a five pick parlay for a
reason it's a long shot let's have some
fun man what do you got for us connor
you might you might gotta you might want
to cash out a little early i probably
will you know i mean i won't tell you
guys but i probably will
yeah
it's all good but let me let me tell
y'all man my boat is bet today i think
it is going to be a track meet in
detroit
so the niners uh i took the alternate
spread here i'm taking the niners
alternate spread in detroit i think that
they're gonna win by more than two
touchdowns this one might get ugly
connor uh
the lions they their offensive line is
depleted they don't have their left
tackle and we know this 49ers defensive
line likes to get after the quarterbacks
full of first-round picks uh and guys
who just love to get to the quarterback
so i see this one being ugly raheem
moser trey sermon maybe might see some
trey lance today connor
it might get ugly out there in detroit
yeah with the niners minus 13. i'm with
you all the way i think this is going to
be a blowout i think the lions are
clearly in a rebuild i think that niners
pass pass rush is going to get jared
goff you know off platform not a pretty
place for him to be we know the niners
can run the ball kyle shanahan probably
the best
run game planner in the entire league
going back to when his dad was the coach
of the broncos this guy has lived
running the football so the niners today
are big i love that you bought that up i
feel like that's as high as they let you
go is that -13 niners win by two
touchdowns are the people agreeing with
either of us or are we just both insane
uh let me see let me see connor i am in
the comments uh
i got d magahi one d magahi one says
kyle pitts a hundred percent young stud
i just had to give him that because he
he switched him through a curveball we
were talking about him with your parlay
so shout out to you uh dean mcgonney one
you are walking away with a hoodie uh
let me see i see niners only please for
greg every week joe yan i see you i see
you the niners gonna win you some money
just watch just watch uh here we go
connor to be honest bro
we smith 44 said rolling with g money
niners by 21 plus shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie should
i give away a uh think of it jersey yeah
i was about to say should i just give
away a jersey right now yes
all right here we go here we go here we
go giving away
a jersey giving away a jersey all right
here we go connor
94 says riding with connor let's go
crazy of a parlay not that crazy of a
parlay plus the hunt leg oh i lost it i
lost it but he said plus the hunt leg so
and he was riding with you connor so
therefore
oh here we go he set the hunt like the
the hunt leg
the receiving uh uh the receiving
yards for kareem hunt he said that's
what sold him that's what sold him shout
out to you bella zara i'm sorry if i'm
butchering your name 94 you are walking
away with the jersey connor
football it's about that time almost
upon us it might be time to get on the
body here
man i think it is good luck with all
your wagers everyone let's make some
money today as greg always says winners
only please congrats to all the hoodies
and jersey winners i think a lot of you
are walking away quite happy today and
if you're not come back next week we do
this every sunday 11 a.m getting the
bleacher report app you're on the west
coast wake up a little early greg does
it why can't everyone else do it if you
won vr betting is going to dm you greg
and i can't help in that regard we can
only give this stuff away we are betting
he's going to find a way to contact you
and make sure you get everything thank
you to everyone that commented thank you
to the legends matt dan hardig tsuji
riley sorbo and w tramwell a lot of
creativity was brought for week one and
it's only going to get better from here
enjoy your football sunday drop your
real time takes in this whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa we got a little more a little
more connor connor
i know this is your second show but i
gotta give the people love at the end of
the show they're here for the hoodies
they're here for the jerseys so you know
man i'm a man of the people i gotta hook
him up but i'm back into the comments
connor i'm back into the comments real
quick to give away some more hoodies to
the people that stuck around to the end
of the show the real i got
the real ones the real ones the real
ones i got not mitch trabisky ayuk is a
lock they're riding with you connor with
your play with brandon and i you can
over three and a half receptions shout
out to you not mr biscuit you're walking
away with hoodie
o-m-e-e-d-n-a-i-d-n-a-e-m-i i'm not even
gonna try to pronounce that
producers that was for the producers
they said waddle waddle is a lot i like
the rookie from alabama shout out to you
you walk away with a hoodie
that's it that's it one more daniel levy
daniel levy you're walking away with a
hoodie shouts out to you okay that's it
oh man i love it alongside the man of
the people greg ivory i'm connor rogers
come back same time same place every
week get a hoodie get a jersey get some
locks make some money thanks everyone
catch you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you